[Música]
Estados Unidos se prepara para las
elecciones de medio término del 8 de
noviembre que renovarán los 435 escaños
de la cámara baja y a un tercio del
senado un reto para el gobierno de Joe
biden que se juega la gobernabilidad a
la mitad de su mandato
y en esos comicios Pensilvania es uno de
los estados que podrían decidir el
control del Congreso pero donde existe
mucha tensión por las acusaciones de
fraude electoral por parte de Donald
Trump en 2020 tenemos reportes sobre el
terreno
y una semana después de la victoria de
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva en las
elecciones de Brasil siguen las
manifestaciones de lo listas y
bolsonaristas en el país Río de Janeiro
y Brasilia son dos de las principales
ciudades en donde hubo movilizaciones
este domingo
bienvenidos al nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano se
Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos abrimos este Informativo en
Estados Unidos
quedan dos días para que el país se
enfrente a las elecciones de medio
término los estadounidenses están
llamados a las urnas para renovar
completamente los 435 escaños de la
cámara baja y elegir a un tercio del
senado de ganarlas el partido
republicano quedaría en el aire la
capacidad de gobernabilidad del gabinete
bailén un impulso para un Donald Trump
que ya insinuado que podría volver a
presentarse en 2024 ante esta
perspectiva Joe biden declaró Nueva York
en un acto de campaña que el país se
juega un futuro político de los próximos
20 años
y la elección más importante de nuestras
vidas va a tomar forma en este país por
décadas estamos en uno de esos puntos de
inflexión lo digo sinceramente donde lo
que va a suceder en los próximos dos
años tendrá más que ver con Cómo se ve
este país dentro de 20 años que
cualquier otra cosa ya sabes seamos
claros
en estas elecciones el estado de
Pensilvania es uno de los que podrían
decidir el control del parlamento pero
donde muchos votantes y trabajadores
electorales tienen miedo después de las
amenazas que vivieron tras el lento
conteo de resultados en las elecciones
presidenciales de 2020 un equipo de
France 24 estuvo en una de las oficinas
que vigila estos comicios en Pensilvania
entramos en la oficina del comisionado
electoral de Pensilvania
desde aquí Omar savir promueve y asegura
la participación de los votantes Lo
mismo hizo los comicios presidenciales
del 2020 y por eso recibió estas
amenazas
en hablar
hace su trabajo con miedo
yo diría con más conciencia y con más
propósito siento que incluso si mi vida
se perdiera por el trabajo que estoy
haciendo merece la pena creo que la
democracia no tiene precio
aceptos Pero encontrar 8.500
trabajadores para los más de 1.700
centros de votación no está siendo nada
fácil porque hay miedo los funcionarios
insisten en que la seguridad está
garantizada
hay cosas que es mejor no hacer públicas
pero quiero asegurar que todo el mundo
estará seguro como siempre ha estado
entendemos que hay preocupa bien estamos
al tanto de eso y estamos trabajando en
ello
imposible que haya fallos en la boleta
Esta es nuestra boleta de prueba Estas
son las máquinas donde ya se está
votando de manera anticipada pero lo
mejor de estas máquinas es que tienes un
recibo de verificación
una garantía de que ninguna boleta se
pierde no seleccionaré ningún candidato
para quienes votan por correo los 18.000
buzones que hay en la ciudad están
controlados por cámaras de
videovigilancia como esta Pensilvania es
un estado clave para determinar el
control del senado y también la futura
agenda política del presidente joeyden
es una de las pocas oportunidades que
tienen los demócratas de quitarles un
escaño a los republicanos pero aquí los
resultados están muy ajustados y la
participación en mayor o menor medida va
a ser decisiva por eso el candidato
republicano trata de ganar votos entre
los latinos pero su agenda electoral no
convence a votantes como Karen ponlo de
migración de que están con los de o y
todo eso los afroamericanos también
pueden decidir al ganador porque están
más indecisos que nunca
y así está haciendo este comisionado
espera una de las mayores cifras de
participación que se han visto en los
últimos años nos vamos a Brasil porque
siguen las manifestaciones tanto de
simpatizantes del presidente saliente
Yair bolsonaro como del presidente
electo Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva Río de
Janeiro y Brasilia fueron dos de las
principales ciudades del país que
vivieron este domingo una nueva jornada
de estas concentraciones Samuel Salgado
nos amplía
una semana después de la victoria de
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva en las urnas
simpatizante del presidente saliente de
Brasil Jair bolsonaro continúan con las
manifestaciones en las principales
ciudades del país
estoy aquí hoy porque quiero la libertad
de Brasil No aceptamos el comunismo
los simpatizantes del presidente extrema
derecha se rehúsan a aceptar a la
izquierda y ya dos veces presidente Lula
Quien ganó las elecciones del pasado 30
de octubre con un estrecho margen de los
votos válidos algunos de los
manifestantes bolsonaristas llevan
varios días ocupando las calles y
protestando frente a cuarteles generales
del ejército de Brasil para pedir una
intervención militar
llegó aquí cuatro días y no me rendiré
nuestro Brasil necesita ayuda
pero el entusiasmo bolsonarista parece
menguar ya no se encuentran activos la
gran mayoría de los bloqueos de Los
camioneros por las rutas del país por su
parte manifestantes a favor de Lula
también salieron a las calles y
organizaron una fiesta para exorcizar a
Brasil de bolsonaro
es el Día de exorcizar a evolucionado
exorcizar a la derecha acabar con los
prejuicios acabar con la xenofobia y la
homofobia ya es suficiente
es el Renacimiento de Brasil nos estamos
convirtiendo en Brasil otra vez el
presidente Yair bolsonaro no ha aceptado
explícitamente La derrota pero prometió
que respetará la constitución en un
breve pronunciamiento lo que redujo los
temores de una transición de poder
violenta según la prensa brasileña el
gobierno electo de lulada Silva planeada
derogar decretos dictados por Yair
bolsonaro como primeras acciones de
gobierno entre ellas estarían los que
facilitan el acceso a las armas
dificultan el combate a la deforestación
y el decreto para el secreto de la
información para estas derogaciones no
se necesita una mayoría parlamentaria
anteriormente pudimos hablar con Darío
piñotti analista político y corresponsal
en Brasil de la agencia italiana ansa
que nos hablaba sobre las legislaciones
que más daño han hecho Al cuidado de la
amazonía y cuáles urge del hogar
básicamente el de restablecer los
controles para impedir que sean
invadidas tierras protegidas y que sean
invadidas también áreas de grupos de
pueblos originarios Esos son los dos
puntos claves prometidos por una que
incluso anunció que va a crear una
autoridad para defensa de la amazonia
una especie de comité independiente del
gobierno y que se prolongará Más allá de
la cuestión tenga en cuenta que por otra
parte Lula la próxima semana no la
entrante la otra viajará Egipto para
tomar parte de la Cumbre ambientalista
con 27 donde posiblemente confirmará
estos anuncios y donde será recibido
prácticamente como un presidente en
funciones porque el actual ya ir
evolucionado Aparentemente no tomará
parte en ese evento y cerramos en México
con una buena noticia para el planeta
cientos de crías de tortuga marina
fueron liberadas en las costas del
Pacífico el estado de Chiapas está
comprometido desde el año 1991 con la
protección de este reptil por lo que su
preservación camina de la mano con el
equilibrio del ecosistema del lugar los
detalles con laurel
niños y adultos mirando el retorno al
mar de 500 tortugas en esta Playa del
Pacífico mexicano hace un poco más de 30
años que se realizan operaciones de
liberación de tortugas marinas todo
empieza en el sitio de admiración donde
se monitorea de manera permanente y se
cuida a los nidos en una lucha para
conservar el hábitat natural de las
especies cuando incubamos En la
temporada de Julio a diciembre que se
llena un Corral Pero se tiene que pasar
al siguiente Corral para que se pueda
seguir el seguimiento y no perder Ahora
sí ningún ningún este nidos en las
playas para poder recuperarlo y traerlo
a los corra de incubaciones los miembros
de la organización se dicen felices con
los resultados entre otras cosas el
aumento de la llegada de hembras
anidadoras gracias a la consolidación de
cuatro campamentos de tortuga en Chiapas
pero a pesar de que existe un trabajo de
concientización los biólogos e
investigadores siguen luchando contra
los saqueadores vividos tal como la
crisis climática aparecer las tortugas
Aunque pareciera que no son tan
importantes sin embargo sí lo son este
vamos a desencadenar un desequilibrio
ecológico aparte con estos efectos del
cambio climático que se están dando del
aumento de las temperaturas como sabemos
los reptiles este su sexo está
determinado por la temperatura
las especies que arriban a estas playas
del océano Pacífico corresponden a
cuatro grupos entre ellas está en la
tortuga verde negra Carey golfina y laud
todas en peligro de extinción
hasta aquí este repaso informativo sigan
conectados a France 24
[Música]